I grew up on a beef farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock we raised a lot of our own
feed to stay in business and we raised
corn and soybeans and hay and we grind
this stuff up into a flower and we'd had
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
make pellets you feed those calves for
about six nine months and then you ship
them off to be butchered or maybe two
other feeders and you always save back
the very best ones for yourself and you
knock them in the head need them it's a
real simple cycle on the farm and the
thing that fascinated me as a teenager
was that we went to a great deal of
trouble for those calves and yet as a
family we ate out of the very same
fields we keep back five rows of corn
for ourself we had a garden at the end
of the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes and we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calves and I always used to ask my
daddy say hey pops how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and not
for ourselves and he'd say shut up boy
getting farm fresh food fresh air Lance
the free exercise don't ask complicated
questions and I was glad to get rid of
the forum exercise and go to AG school
at the University of Missouri and there
my major was an animal husbandry
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre and
a gekka nomics but I didn't get an
answer to my basic question until I
became a freshman veterinary student at
the University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals and animal feeds bottom line is
because we don't have insurance for them
we don't have Blue Cross Blue Shield
major medical hospitalization Medicare
Medicaid and if we were to use a human
health care type assistant for animals
it'd be sticker shock for you your
hamburger would cost you 275 dollars a
pound boneless skinless chicken breast
be 450 bucks a pound dozen eggs be fifty
dollars just to pay for the health care
so we learned that we could keep the
price of animal products such as meat
and dairy and poultry and eggs down to
where the average American could afford
them simply by significantly reducing or
totally eliminating health care costs
and we do that in animals by preventing
and curing diseases with nutrition well
after graduating vet school I went to
Africa for a couple of years and got to
work with Marlin Perkins from the old
mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom days and
I was kind of a kick
got to play Frank buck use a
tranquilizer gun trample over central in
South Africa for a couple of years and
then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States he'd
gotten a seven-and-a-half million dollar
grant from the National Institutes of
Health and this was more than 30 years
ago and this was the study pollution and
ecology in the environment and my job is
the wildlife veterinarian on the project
was to do autopsies of animals who died
of natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States and I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals
was ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use Canaries
you know how that goes i take the canary
down in the mine and if methane gas or
carbon monoxide were to leak in the mind
the Canaries were more sensitive than
the men and would drop off the Persian
die and long before the men were in
danger of suffocating or blowing up well
to make a long story short after some 12
plus years of working on this project
and done some 17,500 autopsies and over
450 for species of animals plus 3,000
human beings for a comparison and what I
learned was that every animal and human
being who dies of natural causes dies of
a nutritional deficiency disease and I
got kind of excited about nutrition
again and I wrote 75 scientific papers
on the subject wrote chapters 48
multi-author textbooks actually
contributed a textbook myself a thousand
pages 2,000 illustrations and through
the news releases that run the big
universities I worked with I was on
20-21 1,700 newspapers around the world
through the UPI and AP news wire
services and with all this public
exposure and with all the scientific
exposure I couldn't get people who are
in a position of authority either in
medical research or in politics to get
too concerned or interested in
preventing and curing diseases and human
beings with nutrition just like we did
in animals well I got frustrated enough
I went back to school in Portland Oregon
became a physician and I practiced there
for 12 years as a general family
practitioner and I sewed up chainsaw
wounds delivered babies used everything
that I learned in veterinary nutrition
of my human patients and it was no
surprise to me that it worked just as
well in people as it did in animals well
to get started I always like to talk
about longevity and the human being has
the
genetic potential to live healthily to
be 120 I'm going to prove that to you in
just a minute unfortunately Americans do
a lousy job when it comes to longevity
our average lifespan the United States
is 75.5 about half or genetically
capable of in 1990 when the World Health
Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations on earth the
United States came out 17th there's
actually 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do we ranked
19th and healthfulness that meant that
there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do before
they develop heart disease and cancer
and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis we ranked 23rd when it came
to live birth and first-year survived
abilities of babies and we ranked dead
last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defects now what all
this means is we have the highest price
healthcare system in the world but not
the best it also means that we have the
most envied health care system in the
world but not the best we have the most
technologically advanced healthcare
system in the world but not the best I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher Byrd for many many years
over 20 years in Chris I was a
best-selling author on books on
organically grown food he was an expert
in the subject and I was always trying
to give him vitamins and minerals and he
refused to take him and he'd tell me doc
I bring my own cooler I don't eat any
Hotel food I bring my own organically
grown food and so I don't need to take
vitamins and minerals well I was
changing planes again in Atlanta had an
hour to kill picked up the local
newspaper and guess whose obituaries
found in the newspaper Chris bird for us
again he was a best-selling author of
books the secret life of plants the
secrets of the soil and he died at age
68 from a ruptured aneurysm a type of
stroke seven and a half years before the
average American dies and he led a
pristine life lived up in the mountains
had an organically grown garden
collected herbs you know like you'll get
ins and ate wild hickory nuts and all
those kind of things and because of his
belief he died of a copper deficiency
and I'll show you in a minute that
copper deficiency causes ruptured
aneurysms and it's just a tragic thing
that the people have so much to give and
die at less than half their genetic
potential for longevity a lot of people
say to me doc I don't need to take
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
because I use herbs now herbs are not
nutrition you have to understand that
herbs are not nutrition they are great
plant medicines they're safer they're
more economical in most cases
more effective than prescription
medications that doctors will give you
but their plant medicines if you have
diarrhea they can tighten you up if you
have constipation they loosen you up if
you have a hypertension or high blood
pressure and bring it down if you have a
fever and bring it down but don't expect
to get enough calcium or selenium or
boron or copper or vitamin A from herbs
well I've been doing biomedical research
and clinical research and animals and
human beings and I can tell you no
matter how you look at health and
longevity whether it be in animals or
human beings there's only really two
concepts you have to deal with concept
number one I refer to as avoid stepping
on the landmines this is where you don't
want to throw away your healthy physical
body wastefully you don't want to smoke
don't abuse alcohol don't do drugs don't
jog down the highway at two o'clock in
the morning wearing an all black ninja
suit you're going to get hit by a truck
mirror right whenever a doctor says
here's our options never say doc
whatever you say you're the you're the
doctor when a doctor says here's our
options what you want to do is take a
look I want copies of all these records
and test I want copies of the x-rays and
go visit three other doctors and three
other hospitals you want to talk to 12
of their living patients that had gone
through this procedure talk to him see
if you really want to do this I mean you
do this for your driveway and your roof
and your fence in your yard and all that
kind of stuff why not for your own
physical body that's concept number one
now that you've avoided the landmines
you're in a good position to do all the
positive things that you need to do to
go on to live to be over 100 basically
what you want to do is take all in
essential nutrients 60 that's 60 mineral
16 vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids they're
called essential nutrients for two
reasons number one your body cannot
manufacture them you must consume these
every day there is food or supplements
number two if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
months couple of years you get on the
average 10 deficiency diseases you have
everything to gain doesn't lose by
supplementing properly well medical
profession of course has this malignant
dumb belief that you can get everything
you need from your four food groups my
favorite article of all time in the
press was april six 1992 Time magazine
cover article the real power of vitamins
new research shows and may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging six positive pages if you haven't
read it I'd urge you to go to a public
library school library dig it out and
read it there was only one negative
sentence and as you might guess it was
offered by a medical doctor who was
actually contacted by the writer of the
article said what do you think about
vitamins and minerals and and trace
minerals as supplements for human
nutrition here's what he said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do any good
sniffs dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote now Missouri translation
of that is you're just peeing away your
money my is a lot up your dollars throw
in a toilet and flush them away and get
everything you need from your four food
groups is what he's trying to say well
I'd rather be out fifty cents or a
dollar day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals that's cheap insurance think
about how much money to spend for coffee
or soft drinks or newspapers and that
kind of stuff every day fifty cents to a
dollar day to maintain and repair your
body and it's kind of fascinating that
most people don't do it just remember
when you pay that doctor out of your own
pocket or indirectly through insurance
or indirectly through taxes and Medicare
Medicaid not a single penny of that goes
to better understand manage treat
prevent or cure catastrophic diseases
and kids breast cancer and women
prostate cancer in men now a lot of
people ask me why did you call your
original tape dead doctors don't lie
well that's because I believe for a long
time because i had done medical research
for over 20 years in large medical
research institutes medical schools the
various laboratories and i always had a
belief in the medical system but i was
very disappointed when I learned that
doctors don't know the most about health
and longevity doctors don't know the
most about disease they do know about
procedures you know how to fix your
bones when you break them that sort of
thing how to do a cat scan and so I
began to look in the medical journals
and sure enough the first article ever
published on health and longevity of
American doctors is published in JAMA in
June fifteenth 1895 little over a
hundred years ago he said at that time
doctors lived to be 54.6 I redid the
study 97 years later using the same
obituaries that they did in JAMA this
was january twentieth nineteen ninety
three in a particular issue of jama and
it turned out the doctors lived to be
57.6 i rounded up to 58 to give him the
benefit of the doubt and doctors just
went berserk when I said that I mean
this was the most outrageous thing that
ever heard my principle is my premise is
that doctors don't live as long as the
average couch potato in America and I
purposely put that figure out there 58
to try and challenge people well doctors
immediately looked at all the insurance
actuarial charts they got 250,000 dead
doctors you see your groups too small so
they
to 250,000 dead doctors they say doctors
don't live to be 58 they died 62 they
still don't live to be 75.5 like the
average couch potato we actually reran
this again using the entire obituaries
history for 1996 and in for the entire
1996 of all the doctors dying in 1996
with all the medical treatments and
drugs and procedures and everything and
transplants doctors and in that study
lived to be 70 still five and a half
years shart of the average couch potato
in America so they still have never
proven that doctors live as long as
everybody else that's why dead doctors
don't lie now if you do everything right
how old can you live to be is it worth
all the effort I believe it is here's
one Christian Mortensen from san rafael
california in august of 1995 turned 113
august 1996 he turned 114 he's still
going strong certainly can live to be
115 smokes couple of cigars a day like
George Burns who also live to be over
100 certainly was a guess the only
exercise George Burns ever did was put
the cigars in his mouth this gal here
Dora Rama Thebe from South Africa in
July of 1995 turned 114 and when she was
asked by the media Dora what do you
attribute your health and longevity to
she did not say that we owe it all to
our annual physical are our HMO she said
I ate locust every day you know a little
grasshopper she's not a vegetarian she's
little animals pumpkin seeds tortoise
meet wild herbs dried fruit and starts
each day with a cup of coffee this gal
here Margaret skeets from radford
virginia in 1994 was the oldest
documented living American when she died
at age 115 fell over and fractured her
hip three weeks later she was dead from
complications of osteoporosis a simple
calcium deficiency and we'll talk more
about this in a minute unfortunately
this is not unusual 75% of all americans
over the age of 65 who fractured hip or
major leg bone don't live 90 days they
die of pneumonia pulmonary embolism
stroke and other complications of that
fracture Susie Brunson occurring to her
family in December of 1994 was the
oldest American when she died at age 123
and they base their claim on her
birthdate December 25th 1870 which was
recorded in the family Bible in this
fellow here Francisco Barisan wave at
chop arena khobor 1995 he was from a
little town outside of Bogota Colombia
turn 125 when he was asked by the media
Francisco what do you attribute your
health
longevity to he said well I drink a
gallon of goat's milk every day also is
kind of fascinating in his birthday
announcement this is not a ooh err
this is birthday announcement said that
over 40 years ago his physicians told
him he only had a couple of months to
live so he had his sons building a
coffin and he's been waking up every
morning for more than 40 years sitting
by that coffin waiting to die goodnight
time comes he goes to bed wakes up the
next morning since by the coffin ways to
die now he's still going strong and all
the doctors who told him that more than
40 years ago or a long since dead now
this fellow here how moody al-abdullah
from Syria died aged 133 and he was
still fathering children after the age
of 100 he remarried for the fourth time
when he was age 80 bothered for boys
five girls nine children after the age
of 80 with the same wife and we add up
the pregnancies in the breastfeeding the
time in between pregnancies he was still
fathering children after the age of 100
this very next one is my very very
favorite this gal mazuma dusty from iran
according to the Rocky Mountain News
wire services out of Denver and the
Iranian news agency this was January of
1995 she died at age 161 now you have to
give a certain amount of credibility to
this obituary report that she died aged
161 because she is survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
to 128 they hadn't even left home to go
to college yet
now her oldest son Gollum said his
mother had never visited a doctrine are
taking any chemical medications during
her life did take a few herbs so if you
kind of think about it every one of
these people who live to be over a
hundred 120 130 160 these people are not
from United States or Canada or Germany
or England kind of interesting isn't it
there most of them are from third world
countries their furthest away from
medical help and they lived the old so
that we're beginning to collect
information here the last one we want to
look at the National Geographic Society
a very respected group of people
scientists and so forth and support
groups for science comes out with a
monthly magazine the National Geographic
magazine of course and they in January
of 1973 came out with a nifty special
issue on longevity they looked at
cultures whose people have 120 and they
documented the oldest living human being
that they could find based on their
criteria this fellow by the name of Sher
Ali mismo law from Azerbaijan a little
country just south of Russian Georgia in
western Russia today they documented him
as being a hundred and sixty-seven years
old remember this is the National
Geographic Society not the national
enquirer 167 years of age and they had a
half page picture of him actually
harvesting tea leaves and a tea
plantation still working eight hours a
day six days a week when he's 167 five
months later may of 1973 shirali mismo
off turns 168 goes out and hosed the
garden for reporters to show how
vigorous he is now for at least 15 maybe
70 years medical doctors in america have
been pooh-poohing the idea that you can
live well beyond 100 you know people who
lived 115 120 they were one in six
billion it wasn't something that
everybody could look forward to and
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110 120 hundred forty were
considered charlatans and quacks and
taking advantage of older people I was
glad to see this come out this was a
news article in the USA Today newspaper
in October of two thousand and it was
based on a article in the journal
Science very respectable journal and
what they said was forget a hundred try
living past 120 humans possess a maximum
life expectancy longer than 120 years
which had been the long theorized
medical limit in fact lifespans appear
to be increasing over time with no end
in sight now the cute part of this is
now that there's no doubt about it
everybody agrees that human beings
including Americans have the genetic
capacity to live well beyond 120 doctors
want to take credit for the things that
have actually increased our longevity
from 45 average lifespan in 1895 to 75.5
today which is an increase of about 30
and a half years our sewers and good
clean water public health things we
don't have cholera and leptospirosis and
tuberculosis and our food supply nor
water supply anymore we have meat
inspection we have public waterworks and
things have sewers these are the things
that have extended our lifespan then
there's this salt thing you know would
you believe it or not this medical
dogmas really cause a lot of problems in
America how many have ever heard that
using a salt shaker is bad you're going
to get hypertension right you're going
to get heart disease and stroke what's
the first thing a good farmer puts out
for his livestock a salt block or salt
lick in it there's nobody out in the
pasture telling a cow she's limited to
one like a day
I refuse to believe my human patients
are dumber than a cow say look go ahead
and pick up a salt shaker you're going
to see the lightning won't strike you
you can go ahead and saw your food and
tasting saw your body nothing bad is
going to happen in ninety-eight percent
of my patients love it they bring me
hundreds of new patients every month who
want to use salt and not to feel guilty
about it then two percent the bean
counters they see in a wallet we love
you respect you we have this high priced
cardiologist that says you're flying in
the face of all the way to medical
evidence you can't tell people that they
can use a salt shaker because you're
going to kill them with high blood
pressure and heart disease and stroke
and I've been vindicated in this belief
this was actually a study that was
published in The New York Times may 22nd
1996 and this study was abstracted from
JAMA the journal the American Medical
Association the most prestigious medical
journal in the world according to
themselves now in this particular
journal a dr. Alexander Gordon Logan
who's an epidemiologist and cardiologist
on the teaching staff of the medical
school at the University of Toronto up
in Canada and he took 56 existing
studies on hypertension or high blood
pressure and restriction of salt combine
the data from these 56 studies which
included 35 hundred and five people he
threw away all the conclusions and
re-evaluated the larger group and what
he found out was this if you have normal
blood pressure and you're restrict salt
it will not prevent you from getting
heart disease or high blood pressure if
you have hypertension or high blood
pressure and restrict salt ninety-seven
percent of those with high blood
pressure or hypertension who restrict
salt will not get any measurable benefit
ninety-seven percent will not get any
measurable benefit 0 to 25 percent get
measurable benefit but it's not
significant they're only able to reduce
their blood pressure by three point
seven millimeters of mercury so here's
what dr. Alexander Gordon Logan said in
JAMA may 22nd 1996 he said you might as
well go ahead and saw your food to taste
it's a meaningless exercise don't get
paranoid about salt it has nothing to do
with blood pressure problems there has
never been one single iota of proof the
restricting salt has any benefit is just
one of those medical myths he called it
but I'm going to call it a medical kaka
now if it's not salt what causes high
blood pressure well it's not salt first
of all because salt is an essential
nutrient has a combination of sodium and
chloride both of which you need and
according to the American Heart
Association the minimum daily
requirement for 150-pound person for
salt each day is a heaping teaspoon six
to nine grams of salt today now the
Japanese who live longer than we do the
Japanese who live 4.1 years longer than
we do and have half the cancer rate they
eat 12 grams of salt a day the three
times assault we do and they live for
years longer have half the
cardiovascular disease rate and half the
cancer rate we do and yet they eat three
times as much salt as we do so you're
beginning to put the puzzle together the
doctors really don't know what they're
talking about that's why dead doctors
don't lie well if it's not the salt and
if it's not genetic what is it well it's
actually just a simple mineral
deficiency raise your hand you ever
heard the cholesterol is bad and you got
to get it low in your blood you got to
have low cholesterol diet otherwise
you're going to get heart disease right
doctors would like to blame all
cardiovascular disease on cholesterol we
have known for 75 years in animal
industry their cholesterol is not a
bogeyman there's not a single disease
that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides you can find
me one I'll give you a million dollars
in small bills in any offshore account
you want there is not a single diseases
caused by elevated blood cholesterol
triglycerides elevated blood cholesterol
and triglycerides are really just a
warning signal much like a fever fevers
don't cause infections but when you have
an infection with a bacterial virus of
fungus maybe a parasite you can get a
fever you have a broken leg and get up
here you can have cancer and get a fever
you have liver disease and get a fever
babies get a fever when they teeth and
so you have to kind of sort it out when
somebody comes into a doctor's office
with a fever you have to say well okay
here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis all the things
cause fever if they're 80 years old you
can quickly rule out teething right but
the rest of you may have to do some lab
tests for any rate the same thing is
true for elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides when you have elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides it
might mean that you have hypothyroidism
or low functioning thyroid gland you
could have diabetes you can have
deficiencies of niacin chromium vanadium
the essential fatty acids you can have
liver disease all kinds of reasons why
you might have elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides but then
themselves don't cause any problems now
the eskimos above the Arctic Circle have
a traditional diet does 98% red meat and
blubber they will
meet whale blubber walrus meat while was
blubber seal meat seal blubber bear meat
bear fat there's not a single Eskimo
above the Arctic Circle it has a mr.
Juiceman juicer eats our gang clear and
broccoli their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350 and yet their
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us then when they
get the cardiovascular disease they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle they started eating whale blubber
again it goes away learning all that I
felt very confident in telling my
patients look we're going to do
something different my goal is a
physician is to have my patients died an
average age of 100 I don't want my
patients down at 75.5 I want to give
them another 25 years I want the average
lifespan for my patients to be a hundred
and we're going to do something
different if you want to do everything
that all the other doctors and patients
are doing I want you to go to them
because I don't want you to lower my
average right we're going to do
something different it's just real
simple my favorite diseases arthritis I
love arthritis the reason why i love
arthritis is it's easy to fix and when
you can fix something as horrible and as
debilitating as painful as expensive and
as miserable as arthritis get kind of
excited about this concept of preventing
and cheering diseases with nutrition and
so i tell people about this arthritis
sing all the time so let's have a quick
look at our thry dose number one seventy
five to eighty percent of all americans
over the age of 50 get arthritis to one
degree or one type or another and
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control 35 to 50 million baby
boomers are going to get arthritis in
the next seven to ten years and there's
not a single medical treatment design to
prevent or fix it aspirin certainly
doesn't fix arthritis because the
gastric bleeding and death cowan all
doesn't fix arthritis causes 50,000
cases of kidney failure each year 5,000
which are so severe you need a kidney
transplant then there is IV profen advil
and aleve these things don't fix
arthritis and they cause liver disease
and two to five percent of the users
including liver cirrhosis even if you
don't drink and then there's
methotrexate and gold shots these things
don't fix arthritis they subdue your
bone marrow so you can't make normal
platelets and white blood cells and then
you have the grand daddies of all the
medical treatments for arthritis
prednisone and cortisone they don't fix
arthritis they subdue your immune system
which leaves you open to diseases far
far more horrible than arthritis and
prednisone and cortisone accelerate the
loss of minerals from your bones
don't want when you have osteoporosis
and arthritis now when these
prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and I never
like to send my patients in for the
joint replacement surgery because they
never work out well in fact many times
you're worse off after the surgery than
you were before the surgery the
advantage of my patients have always had
is that I'm a veterinarian as well as
physician and so I always used to tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
cure diseases and animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formulas designed
to prevent and cure arthritis and
pigeons and turkeys dogs cats sheeps
pigs horses cows lions tigers and bears
to human use it was no surprise me it
works just as well in humans as a dozen
animals because it was designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and pigs and
I literally seen tens of thousands of
people who have had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone foundation bone matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 I've seen people 97 years old
regrow Carl jambon even if they had bone
to bone arthritis if there's blood
supply to that joint and at bone they
will regrow bone and cartilage well of
course Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that
well like you can't say those things the
only thing left for people when they get
bone to bone arthritis is joint
replacement surgery and I'd agree with
them if the only raw materials are using
is tylenol in aspirin and prednisone
cortisone we've learned over 50 years
that you can't regrow Carl jambon using
those things one of the basic things of
course at the Harvard Medical School
jumped onto and they said this is so
ridiculous that this couldn't work and
so they took 29 patients arthritis
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over 15 to 20 years they took
them off all their medication wasn't
working for him anyway lined him up for
joint replacement surgery they said look
for 90 days before we do the surgery
they gave him a heaping tablespoon full
of ground of chicken cartilage there are
geez every morning for 90 days they were
sort of chuckling in their beer saying
nothing's going to happen well here's
what happened in 10 days these people
these 29 people had complete relief of
pain inflammation something they hadn't
had in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they
can now open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened without paying to the
fingers wrists elbows and shoulders in
90 days 28 of the 29 were clinically
cured now this is from Harvard Medical
School in the Boston VA
that meant that they had complete return
to the range of motion all the pain
inflammation was gone and their fingers
and toes and hips and knees in her neck
and certainly many of them still had
knots on their fingers because there's
only 90 days and you think they'd call
me up these professors you know of
medicine from Harvard Medical School and
from the Boston VA and say look Wallach
we have to apologize to you we've been
bad-mouthing you for 20 years and why
don't you come up to Boston let's talk
about the whole thing here's what they
said quote after three months it was
clear that the drug is beneficial
unquote chicken cartilage had become a
drug in 90 days now why would that
happen well because you can't patent
chicken cartilage and they convinced
that the US patent office that they were
using a drug to do this study and they
actually got a use patent on chicken
cartilage and you to for 3,500 bucks a
month can get Harvard Medical School's
chicken College in a capsule for
arthritis course cartilage has
chondroitin sulfate in it glucosamine
sulfate collagen these are all the basic
raw materials to rebuild cartilage and
bone raise your hand if you know what
the red warning lights were on the
dashboard of a car truck back before we
had dials showing temperatures and
things that used to use the red warning
light right was called the idiot light
and when that red warning light came on
it meant that your engine was heating up
you didn't have enough coolant or oil or
maybe a broken fan belt or split a
radiator hose a reasonable person would
would pull the vehicle car truck over
the side of the road and deal the
problems they didn't burn the engine
dump even if you know Mercedes would
burn up if you didn't have enough
coolant and oil and a fan belt and
radiator hose then of course the village
idiot that's what they called the
village idiot light or the idiot light
they'd be driving along they see that
red warning light come on is that I
don't have time to deal with this so
they whip out their flowers they cut the
wire the red warning light they keep on
driving even a Mercedes will burn up if
it doesn't have oil cool and a fan belt
and Rader hose right and so you really
have to be the village idiot to do that
nobody in the right mind would do that
to their vehicle how many of you know
what pain is for our raise your hand if
you know what pain as far that's pretty
good most of you know that pain is the
red warning light for your body when you
get pain in your foot your ankle or your
leg your knee your hip your back your
shoulders elbows wrists and fingers
you're by saying don't use those joints
don't use those bones don't use those
muscles until you fix them it's
absolutely criminal absolutely criminal
for a doctor to write you a prescription
for pain reliever an anti-inflammatory
or muscle relaxant or any
those combinations without rebuilding
the bones and the joints in the
cartilage at the same time if they just
give you a pain reliever just give you
an anti-inflammatory and are a muscle
relaxant without rebuilding the joints
and the bones at the same time all
they're doing is cutting the wire the
red warning light you're going to wear
those bones and joints and Cartledge out
faster and faster and faster it's
actually a negative to be taking
painkillers and anti-inflammatories
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time the reason why I
say no carbonated drinks and have been
doing that since nineteen sixty four is
because carbonated drinks action will
neutralize your stomach acid and you
cannot efficiently absorb minerals
digest protein or absorb bottom b12
without stomach acid you have to have
stomach acid like battery acid doctors
have the criminal belief that you don't
need stomach ass and they give you all
these drugs to get rid of your stomach
acid antacids and they give you drugs
and stop producing stomach acid right
they don't want you to have stomach acid
absolutely criminal you can't digest
food and absorb food without stomach
acid I know most of you knew that
carbonated drinks neutralize stomach
acid if you remember back 25 50 75 years
ago when somebody would ask their
doctors say look I just ate it i overate
i over ate a Thanksgiving dinner and I
have heartburn and indigestion what do I
do that was before they had zantac they
say well take some 7up bring some ginger
ale drink some club soda take take some
sparkling water because of carbonation
will neutralize your stomach ass and
give you some relief and it would now if
you do that three times a year drink a
carbonated drink three times a year for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and Easter
because you overeat during those holiday
that's okay you're going to survive when
you're drinking two three four five six
eight ten carbonated drinks a day you're
not going to survive because over the
long haul you will not be able to absorb
the nutrients you're going to get some
horrible combination of terrible
diseases this came out june of two
thousand and this is a harvard study on
460 junior high school girls in 9th and
10th grade and what they found out was
that those junior high school girls who
drank one non cola carbonated drink
every day they increased their risk of
fractures nastya process as a teenager
by 307 they found out that if they drank
one carbonated cola drink a cola
carbonated drink every day they increase
the risk of fractures and osteoporosis
as a teenager by five
now do you think that this is more
dangerous for teenagers or adults it is
much more dangerous for adults because
you only have twenty five percent bone
matrix and you're very very slow to
recover we're teenagers have forty
percent bone matrix and they can recover
in a week's time we learned in 1957 from
a turkey study where they took 250
thousand turkeys and they put him on a
complete turkey pellet trying to get him
to finish for market within a few days
or a week or so of each other and in the
first 13 weeks fully half of 125,000 of
them died farmers were out there every
morning they picked him up every morning
by the bushel basket fold took them to
the state diagnostic lab to see what
they died from when they opened them up
every one of them had died of a ruptured
aortic aneurysm and one of the clever
pathologist says that's got to be due to
a copper deficiency because copper is
required to manufacture the elastic
fibers of arteries and skin and other
tissues and the mechanism of an aneurysm
is identical to the mechanism of a
balloon on a weekend wall of attire you
know when you hit a chuckhole with your
tire you break the cords the internal
pressure blows a balloon you overload
that tire with weight or heated up on a
highway it blows out same way with an
aneurysm when you have a copper
deficiency you get a breakdown in the
elastic fibers in that artery the
internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain
carotid artery the coronary arteries the
large arteries they are to pulmonary
artery renal arteries they blow out you
die suddenly just like you've been shot
well they got excited about this they
doubled the amount of copper in these
pellets the next year they tried to
raise five hundred thousand turkey and
they did not lose a single one from a
ruptured aneurysm they went from a
50-percent lost with zero percent loss
just by adding a little bit of copper to
those pellets so they said well maybe
the same thing is true for humans in
1958 they started looking at copper
deficiency in various species of animals
and humans and here's what they found
out the very first symptom of copper
deficiency is white gray and silver hair
copper is required as a cofactor to
manufacture hair pigment doesn't matter
if it's blonde red brown or black hair
and I see a lot of copper deficiency in
this room I can almost tell you which
people men and women who have colored
there hair get pretty good at that but
being a physician and you don't want to
be like a medical doctor and just treat
the symptoms if you're just coloring
your hair you're treating the symptoms
you need to do the basic thing take some
colloidal copper and if you don't
going to happen is you get a break down
the elastic fibers in your skin and you
start getting crow's feet around the
corners of your eyes in your mouth parts
of your anatomy begin to sag and you
know you're in trouble when your doctor
tells you look I've got a golf buddy
down the hall who's a plastic surgeon
for ten thousand dollars will make you
look 20 years younger but you don't need
a facelift at boobie lift a tummy tuck
or a derriere lift all you need is some
copper and everything will come back up
just like you have a hydraulic jack
under they'll just come right back up
those elastic fibers tighten right up
people say Francine did you get a
facelift you look great you look like
you're 20 years younger if you don't
take some action at that point the next
thing that happens is you got to break
down the elastic fibers and large veins
of your legs and you get varicose veins
you don't take action at that point you
get a break down the elastic fibers and
large veins of your exhaust pipe and you
get hemorrhoids so if you have
hemorrhoids varicose veins things that
sag wrinkles white gray or silver here
the odds are you have aneurysms
developing in you somewhere and you
don't want to of course died suddenly of
a ruptured aneurysm when your body's
been warning you for 10 20 30 years just
remember people don't die suddenly of an
aneurysm it may be you drop and die
think about old Albert Einstein he died
of a ruptured aortic aneurysm at 68
years of age what color was his hair he
was famous for wild white hair wasn't it
I'd like to think the people who win the
Nobel Prize in medicine at least lived
to be 75.5 but they live to be 58 just
like other doctors and of course that's
because they are trained and they
believe and they practice and get
everything you need from your four food
groups doesn't matter if they win the
Nobel Prize or not this guy here dr.
George Kohler was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history 37 years old wins a Nobel
Prize in medicine and he won the nobel
prize in medicine for studying
monoclonal antibodies which are
antibodies trained to attack cancer
cells if they ever get this really
working it'll be great because they
won't have to use chemotherapy anymore
which kills more people in it saves 11
years after winning the nobel prize in
medicine dr. George Kohler now 48 drops
dead of a cardiomyopathy heart attack
because he believed you can get
everything you need from your for food
which doesn't take any selenium died of
a carding my up with a heart attack I
have to tell you why athletes our early
warning system couch potatoes by
definition or people who go to
extraordinary efforts not to sweat right
they make every human effort not to
sweat they're changing the TV channels
honey bring in the popcorn I'm changing
the channels son bring me
TV Guide I'm changing the channels by
contrast athletes have the attitude no
pain no gain and they're out there
sweating and working away power training
strength training running and they sweat
athletes no matter age they sweat more
in five years of couch potatoes doing 70
years and when you sweat you don't just
sweat out potassium and gatorade you
sweat out all 60 essential minerals if
you sweat out all of your selenium and
don't replace it by supplementation
you're a higher risk of getting a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you sweat
out all of your copper and don't replace
by supplementation your high risk of
developing an aneurysm and dying or
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm is what
I'll all of your chromium and vanadium
and don't replace by supplementation in
high risk of getting diabetes and if you
sweat out all of your calcium and
magnesium and boron and zinc and sulfur
and other minerals are required for
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone you're going to get a joint
and bone injury what is the biggest
single cause of an athlete's career
being ended early joint and bone
problems right and that's because they
sweat out all the basic minerals that
they need to maintain those parts that
are body they don't supplement with them
because doctors tell them that they get
everything they need biting or four food
groups well what are the early warning
system for mineral deficiencies we
already told you about white gray or
silver here for a compra deficiency
liver spots are age spots in the back of
your hand side of your face or neck
these things are caused by a selenium
deficiency and you know again about
selenium deficiency then of course you
have toe cramps leg cramps so you have
hypertension these things are all caused
by a deficiency of calcium and if you're
an athlete at age 25 or 15 and you get a
leg cramp as a calcium deficiency your
body's telling you if you don't stop
drinking those Pepsi's and start
supplementing with some calcium by the
time you're 40 50 60 years old you're
going to have arthritis and osteoporosis
but most people say oh I got to get this
high-priced trainer I need somebody who
can give me the massage therapy because
I have a cramp and they don't go and
take their supplements eighty-five
percent of the total mineral in your
body is a calcium there's 147 different
diseases you can get from a calcium
deficiency we're just going to quickly
go over the top 10 when it comes a
number of people affected in the amount
of money involved let's look at
osteoporosis the number ten killer of
adults the United States remember
seventy-five percent of those over age
65 who fractured hip or major leg bone
don't live 90
also is the most horrible disease when
it comes to human misery and dollars
expended osteoporosis think of the
special vans and the lift gates and the
ramps and the elevators the special
plumbing in homes and in public
buildings special parking places
wheelchairs and walkers and canes think
of the beds and the chairs of little
electric motors that lift you up when
you can't stand up by yourself physical
therapist joint replacement surgeries
pharmaceuticals doctor's visits we're
talking billions and billions of dollars
for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency disease now as horrible as a
disease as osteoporosis is in human
beings we don't have osteoporosis and
animals because we don't have Blue Cross
Blue Shield major medical hassles Asian
Medicare and Medicaid to pay for
nonsensical surgical treatments for
mineral deficiency we've learned that by
putting animals who are weaned off their
mothers milk on calcium as soon as
they're weaned they won't get arthritis
and osteoporosis it's amazing how that
works receding gums Dennis and dental
hygienist will tell you to floss and
brush after every meal if you believe
that works I have some oceanfront
property in Montana to sell yeah if you
have receding gums periodontal
gingivitis pyria loose teeth bridges and
plates you actually have osteoporosis of
the facial bones and the jaw bones we
don't get receding gums and animals even
though they don't floss or brush that's
because we've taken care of the
osteoporosis problem and animals
arthritis eighty-five percent of all
arthritis is called wear and tear
arthritis osteoarthritis degenerative
arthritis ankylosing spondylitis these
things are nothing more than
osteoporosis in the joint ends of the
bones hypertension high blood pressure
as you've learned has nothing to do with
salt or salt restriction eighty-five
percent of hypertension not related to
kidney disease which is most of them not
related to kidney disease is in fact a
calcium deficiency insomnia is not a
deficiency of sleeping pills halcyon or
barbiturates it's a deficiency of
calcium kidney stones bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again the
medical profession has a malignant dumb
belief that these things are due to too
much calcium in your diet to give up
calcium when in fact you only get kidney
stones bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits when you have raging
osteoporosis you actually need more
calcium more magnesium not less cramps
and twitches raise your hand how many of
you ever had a toe cramp foot cramp leg
cramp in your life sure that's the first
symptom of a calcium deficiency that mo
people recognize so if you ever had that
sometime in your life you've had a
calcium deficiency then you have PMS the
University of California San Diego came
out and said that eighty-five percent of
the emotional and physical stuff of PMS
can be relieved eliminated and cured
they use the cure word by taking three
times the RDA of calcium low back pain
has nothing to do with disc problems I
know you've heard of people maybe even
yourself have had a dis surgery for back
pain and after the surgery you still had
the pain maybe even worse because back
pain is not caused by disc problems if
you have a disc problem you can have
numbness and tingling maybe even
paralysis it was very severe but disc
problems do not cause pain we learned in
1957 and animals that we could prevent
and cure adult onset diabetes with to
trace minerals chromium and vanadium
1985 the medical school at the
University of Vancouver British Columbia
Canada came out and said the trace
mineral vanadium alone could replace
insulin and adil onset diabetics sized a
dog food has 40 minerals in it always
has chromium vanadium lithium and
selenium ralston purina laboratory rat
pellets has 28 minerals always contains
chromium vanadium lithium and selenium
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new 100-hour bill if you can find me a
human infant formula off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
minerals in it none of them can contain
chromium vanadium or lithium only one
pro site while to actually pros abhiyan
enfamil I believe has 12 because they
put in the selenium the rest of them
don't they have 11 10 9 or 8 minerals
our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get 28
and our kids get 12 or less you don't
have to be a research scientist to
realize why our kids are now getting all
these horrible diseases that used to
occur in people in their 60s 70s and 80s
all these diseases it that doctors are
wondering how does this genetic these
kids shouldn't have this tiller 60 well
that's because they couldn't get it out
of their little can of stuff if it's not
in the can they don't get it again we
need nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins
12 essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids and fortunately over the
thousands of years that human beings
have been around we haven't had to think
much about this because our food plants
are grains vegetables fruits and nuts
take carbon dioxide out of the air and
manufacture long carbon chains many of
which are vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids and this is where this medical
kaka came from that you can get
everything you need from
four food groups because they say well
plants grains fruit specials and us can
manufacture vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids but we've tried this
experiment for 200 years Americans have
eaten better than anybody else in the
world we've had the best quality food in
the world over anybody else and yet we
only live to be 75.5 we don't set any
health and longevity records so if you
want to live to be over 100 can't get it
from eating your four food groups you
can live to be 75.5 you may live 10
years older 10 years younger but on the
average 75.5 so if you want to live to
be over 100 you do have to supplement
with vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids there's three types of minerals
you have to concern yourself with first
of all there's metallic minerals these
are things like oyster shell eggshell
limestone coral calcium seabed minerals
clays various types tums is a popular
one with doctors lactates gluconate
citrates oxide sulfates carbonates these
are nothing but ground of rocks we're
not designed to eat ground up rocks
nobody can show you where humans or
animals are designed to eat ground up
rocks we are designed to get our
minerals by eating plants grains
vegetables fruits and nuts and as a
result plant-derived minerals and herbal
more absorbable than key lated more
absorbable than the elemental or
metallic minerals plant-derived minerals
are liquid they're very small particle
size there's seven thousand times
smaller than a red blood cell this is a
way they're stored in your cells and are
moved around in plant vascular systems
and human vascular systems in the liquid
plant derived form they're negatively
charged I don't know all of the physics
and the chemistry is one of the basic
features of a colloidal mineral it's
negatively charged these three factors
together give you absorbability now the
way it's supposed to be is our food
plants are grains vegetables fruits and
nuts take the elemental or metallic
minerals out of the soil convert them to
minerals for their own use for their own
metabolism and biochemistry and then
animals and people eat these plants that
are enriched with minerals that's how
we're designed to get our minerals
unfortunately we have several problems
here for a hundred years we've used a
simple fertilizer known as NPK we put in
three nutrients into the soil when we
need sixty minerals we put those three
nutrients in the soil for maximum yield
per ton and bushel per acre then of
course we have to understand the
cannot manufacture minerals if they're
not in the soil they're not in the
plants plants only have minerals in them
if they're in the soil plants cannot
manufacture minerals over 90 years at
least we've been deficient in our souls
in America and as a result our food is
deficient and as a result the crops the
grains fruits vegetables nuts that are
grown there are merely deficient and as
a result the animals and people who eat
these mentally deficient crops get
mineral deficiency diseases and the only
way to prevent and cure them as with
mineral supplements
yes I'm a construction worker and I hurt
my back he said that my cartilage damage
is permanent is there anything that can
be done first of all how old are you I'm
28 years old and what do you normally
take for fluid replacement we were
working out in construction what do you
drink during the day water gatorade you
don't drink any soft drinks yes I do
okay cause normally construction workers
drink a couple of liters of pepsi a day
right yeah I can probably put down a
leader program and did you take any
vitamins or minerals that we were
working a construction just recently
started when you were in construction
prior to the Mac problems yeah a lot of
construction workers will tell me well
doc if it ain't in the Pepsi I don't get
it right and so you're a perfect
candidate for the pig arthritis formula
plus the EFA you need all 90 essential
nutrients and give up the bad things
give up the soft drinks in the iced tea
in the lemonade's and and you up the
fried foods and the margins and I can
just tell you with your age you can
honestly expect to see some really
recognizable results in a very very
short time 60 and 90 days and it doesn't
matter what the doctor said if you do
the right things get rid of the bad
stuff take all 90 essential nutrients
making sure you get that collagen and
the glucosamine sulfate and chondroitin
sulfate you will repair your vertebrae
you will repair the cartilage and you
will repair the disk dr. Wallach just
seems like every week I pick up a
newspaper and I see about our young
athletes having problems with their
bodies falling apart what can we give
our athletes and our children so that
they can be healthy and have long lives
that we want as well it's a great
question because most people believe
that exercise is good for you and that
was always a great question you know is
exercise good for you is necessary for
health and longevity and when you
inspect this question you have to look
at professional athletes who spend most
of their teenage years and going through
University and the semi pros and the
pros training and practicing and doing
their events and and if exercise was the
factor in living a long healthful life
athletes should live longer than couch
potatoes but when you look at this
critically couch potatoes in America
live to be 75.5
and the average athlete depending on the
sport and their level of competence
lived to be 62 to 68 far short of what a
couch potato lives to be and of course
athletes suffer from a great many joint
diseases and bone injuries and tendons
and ligaments back neck shoulders ankles
knees and hips and they have to suffer
through an enormous amount of surgeries
to deal with this and athletes developed
some 800 different diseases now what is
it why is it that athletes don't fare as
well as the couch potato was simply
because athletes sweat more in five
years than couch potatoes do in 75 years
and when you sweat you're not just
sweating out Gatorade you're sweating
out all 60 essential minerals and
they're called essential minerals
because if they're missing for any
length of time you get some horrible
degenerative disease many of which are
life-threatening so you don't have to be
a rocket scientist to figure out who's
more likely to be debilitated or even
die of these these life-threatening
diseases an athlete who sweats out
quarts of sweat during an event or
training or practice or a couch potato
who's laying on a couch and air
conditioned dense switching the channels
yelling honey bring in the popcorn
changing the channels and this is very
serious because the Center for Disease
Control says that as many as a hundred
thousand young athletes under the age of
30 a hundred thousand each year die
suddenly during an event or training or
exercise or immediately after an event
from cardiomyopathy heart disease and
ruptured aneurysm and we know that
cardiomyopathy heart disease is due to a
selenium deficiency and ruptured
aneurysms is due to a copper deficiency
so you can begin to put two and two
together why does a ten year old died of
a ruptured aneurysm well you sweat out
all of this copper and you can't get
copper from curly french fries and pepsi
just doesn't work dr. wallach what about
arthritis well arthritis is my favorite
disease because it's easy to fix it's
one of the great myths that the medical
profession perpetuates is that you can't
build bone mass after the age of 50 60
70 years of age you can only slow down
the loss and the reason why they say
that is because they try to rebuild bone
mass using plain calcium whether it's
tums or calcium citrate or carbonator
gluconate ER or lactate and your body
will not retain much or any of the
calcium you
within your bones without first building
new bone matrix you have to have new
bone matrix this is this is rubbery
collagen material that looks like 10 and
her skin and it makes up 25 to 40
percent of our bone wait forty percent
when your child and twenty-five percent
when you're an adult and so it's
absolutely essential if you want to deal
with the wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis effectively you
have to take on 90 essential nutrients
and the best way to do that is with dr.
wallach spigarose riders formula
remember I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and we learned a long time ago
maybe the hundred years ago in
veterinary medicine that we could
actually prevent and reverse maybe even
use the cure word and animals arthritis
simply by giving the animal the raw
material to develop properly and to
maintain repair the joints and so using
this information that we developed in
animals if you use the same concept for
human beings I have literally seen tens
of thousands of people over the years
who had bone to bone arthritis they had
osteoarthritis they have degenerative
arthritis ankylosing spondylitis which
are basically a joint form of
osteoporosis it's osteoporosis the joint
ends of the bones and they've tried all
kinds of medication and of course if you
take medication if you take a painkiller
if you take an anti-inflammatory for
arthritis essentially all you're doing
is cutting the wire the red warning
light pain and a joint says don't use me
until you fix me and by taking a
painkiller by taking a anti-inflammatory
which will reduce pain you're allowing
that joint to be used even though it
would have been painful without the drug
and so you're wearing that joint out
faster and faster and faster and to me
it's criminally negligent for someone to
be prescribed a painkiller or an
anti-inflammatory for joint disease
without repairing the joint at the same
time and this is where the pr's ritis
formula really shines and works just
like a charm and human beings so does
the same apply for bone spurs absolutely
bone spurs are a manifestation of
osteoporosis a person will get bone
spurs and calcium deposits when you have
osteoporosis just the opposite of what a
doctor will tell you and you need more
calcium or mag
easy immune heed the bone matrix you
need to college in the glucosamine
sulfate the chondroitin sulfate and
those bone spurs and the calcium
deposits will actually riorca tech chure
back down to a normal bone takes a
little while takes four to six months to
pull that off but you can do it on a
regular basis absolutely cancer seems to
be striking everywhere in our population
these days what do we have that we can
help people that are facing the
challenge of cancer that's a great
question back at the turn of the century
1895 1901 out of 10 Americans developed
cancer right now it's three out of five
and by the year 2050 is projected two
out of three people are going to develop
cancer in America the onset of cancer
appears to be directly related to the
amount of of carcinogens these are toxic
waste either from agriculture or from
the industrial waste that we find in our
air and our food nor water in the dust
around us and the lack of the ability to
defend against these these carcinogens
in the most common defense mechanism we
have that the one that we have access to
in a very economical way are the
antioxidants like selenium like the
grape seed extract like the green tea
you're looking at vitamin E vitamin C
beta carotene and avoiding fried foods
and margins and and things we have
control of eating as much organically
grown food as possible and according to
the medical school at the University of
Arizona this came out in JAMA the
journal American Medical Association
December twenty-fifth nineteen
ninety-six I mean we're talking about a
great Christmas gift to the American
people they did a wonderful study ten
years it was a double-blind study 1,300
people they gave the study group two
hundred and fifty micrograms which is
one quarter of one milligram and we're
talking an itsy-bitsy amount of slim
they just use selenium alone didn't
change anything else and by giving these
people two hundred and fifty micrograms
one quarter of a milligram of the trace
mineral selenium they were able to
reduce the risk of esophageal cancer by
seventy one percent prostate cancer by
sixty-nine percent greater than
two-thirds colon and rectal cancer by
sixty four percent almost two
lung cancer was reduced by forty-eight
percent with you smoked or not and in a
parallel study from the University of
California San Diego two hundred and
fifty micrograms one quarter of one
milligram of selenium the trace mineral
selenium reduced the risk of breast
cancer by fifty to eighty percent and
the same study showed that if you
already have cancer if you take 250
micrograms of SLAM every day you will in
fact double the Natural History life
expectancy of a particular type of
cancer for instance lung cancer the
natural history is about a year brain
cancer is less than a year uterine
ovarian colon breast cancer is 225 years
prostate cancer is five to eight years
well just by taking two hundred and
fifty micrograms of the trace mineral
selenium every day one quarter of one
milligram according to the University of
Arizona's Medical School you can double
that life expectancy just by doing that
one thing and so if you take the other
antioxidants and give up margins and
fried foods and sugar and caffeine and
avoid as many of the agricultural wastes
and the toxic waste from the industry
that you can you will be able to avoid
an enormous amount of cancer and if you
already have cancer doing other things
such as taking the antioxidants and
getting on macrobiotic diets and and so
forth you can add many helpful years to
your life you can certainly have a
better quality of life and many people
will extend their lives in a great way
10 20 30 40 years obviously there's no
way you can look in somebody's eyes and
say you're the one that's going to live
50 years and so people just have to do
all the right things and they're going
to get the best that can be gotten from
nutrition and the supplements dr.
Wallach I've been a diabetic for about
30 years what can't what kind of
minerals should I take to help me well
first of all are you an adult onset type
2 diabetic or a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic juvenile onset type 1 you are
in insulin-dependent because the
definition of a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic is that you do not make any
insulin and so you will never be able to
wean off of insulin you will always have
to take some insulin but there are two
trace minerals chromium and vanadium
that will make the insulin that you
supplement yourself with very efficient
and most people who are juvenile onset
type 1 diabetics
able to reduce the amount of insulin
they require to stabilizer blusher by
supplementing with the chromium and
vanadium normally a person learns how to
adjust their insulin by taking their
blood sugar once or twice or three times
a day and so you're taught how to adjust
your insulin intake and just by
following what you've been taught as you
supplement with his plant-derived
colloidal and the key lated chromium and
vanadium you will be able to get down to
a new dosage of your insulin and the
value of taking the whole pig arthritis
formula is that there's nothing worse
than paying attention to your blood
sugar levels your insulin intake and
then dying of a ruptured aneurysm
because you didn't sell a supplement
copper are developing cancer because you
didn't supplement with selenium so it's
very important even though you're a
diabetic and that is your primary
immediate concern still over the long
haul of being a health-conscious person
just out of necessity you're going to
have to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and the odds are even though
your juvenile onset type 1 diabetic you
have every honest expectation of living
to be a hundred and symptom-free if you
do everything right yes my questions on
Alzheimer's why is it more prevalent
today that than it was 15 20 years ago
well Ashley alzheimers disease was a
disease that did not exist 40 years ago
alzheimers disease even by another name
could not be found in any medical
dictionary or textbook or taught in any
medical curriculum it only became an
entity in the medical literature 1979
and today it's apparently the number
four killer of adults United States over
the age of 65 behind cardiovascular
disease cancer diabetes and then comes
alzheimers disease and it appears to me
with no doubt that is due to what I call
a physician cause disease because
doctors have have encouraged people in
fact demanded the people give up
saturated fat and cholesterol and move
towards a cholesterol restrictor even a
cholesterol free diet to get their blood
cholesterol down below 200 and they have
created no less than 25 of these
cholesterol deficiency diseases and to
me alzheimers disease is one of the big
ones seventy-five percent of our brain
weight is pure cholesterol is called my
this fatty stuff that insulates each
nerve fiber the brain and spinal cord
and we can only make about ten percent
of our daily need of cholesterol the
other ninety percent must come from the
diet if a person is very very good at
giving up chicken skin and red meat and
dairy and eggs like a doctor would have
them do after about six or eight or ten
years are not going to be able to keep
up with the maintenance and repair needs
of the cholesterol for the Milan and the
brain and spinal cord and so you can
just expect that the person is going to
develop one or more of these 25
physician cause diseases including
acquired seizure disorders and
alzheimers disease now the best way to
avoid alzheimers disease is d a couple
of eggs every morning for breakfast not
cooked in margarine or fried you want to
consume as much as 72 ounces of red meat
every month I know this sounds like a
lot but it's just a quarter pounder day
and you want to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients and when you get to
the vitamin e level you want to have at
least two thousand international units
of vitamin E and you want 500 micrograms
of selenium if you do that even if you
already have Alzheimer's disease you can
expect to have a significant amount of
return of memory great study done by the
University of California San Diego in
the Salk Institute that says by taking
two thousand international units of
vitamin E alone even if you have
advanced Alzheimer's disease you can get
a significant amount of memory returned
i remodeled homes for families you
notice these little children bouncing
off of walls in what to get for
breakfast and a snack after breakfast
and then lunch again normally has sugar
in it is there any correlation here with
a DD absolutely back to turn the century
1895 to 1900 Americans reading a half a
pound of sugar per person per year today
it's a hundred and fifty pounds of sugar
per person per year and somebody out
there is eating 300 pounds because I
don't need any and I can tell you that
there's a direct correlation between the
increase in a DD ADHD depression manic
depression bipolar disease and the
increased consumption of sugar and if
you look at it there's five million
American children school-age children
who are on ritalin and Prozac and emit
from me
other antidepressants in school five
million drugged American kids in the
preschool and elementary school simply
because these kids are sensitive to
sugar like many people are sensitive to
alcohol there's good alcoholics who just
kind of go to sleep and they have a
couple of drinks there's a people who
get boisterous and sing loud Irish songs
when they take a couple of drinks and
there's some people who get violent and
very angry and become dangerous to
themselves and other people child abuse
spouse abuse they abused her neighbors
road rage is another way of looking at
this life-threatening situations people
actually will gain criminal behavior
sometimes because alcohol acts like a
drug in them same way with sugar some
people when they taken sugar they have
low blood sugar and they just get drowsy
and fall asleep some people when they
taken sugar they get hyperactive and
boisterous and actually a DD ADHD and
then there's some people when they take
in sugar again we'll have road rage
they're very very aggressive and
reactive and to be dangerous to
themselves and their families and other
people in the community and to me it's
criminal for coca-cola machines and
candy machines in school and then wonder
why kids beat up on each other shoot
each other well in addition to getting
all the sugar out of their life from
sugar frosted flakes and Pepsi's and
Reese's peanut butter cups and candy and
and pop tarts and syrup on there a goes
they have to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients even little kids
from the moment they're born to develop
properly this includes their emotions
and repair and maintain themselves and
especially lithium chromium and vanadium
and there's an enormous amount of
research in human beings which show that
lithium deficiency results in
hyperactivity a DD ADHD depression manic
depression and criminal behavior and so
have do both and you can avoid all this
it's amazing just within days they will
be perfectly normal little kids my next
question is my husband and I are
thinking about starting the family and
we want to know that the nutritional way
to go okay that's a great question
people always ask me when when the
children need to start taking vitamins
and minerals and the answer is when
they're still an egg is when you want to
start them and so
we've learned in the animal industry and
remember I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician we've learned in the animal
industry that we could prevent as much
as ninety-eight percent of all birth
defects even ones that are thought to be
genetic in humans simply by giving the
females especially the females all known
essential nutrients for that species six
months prior to conception build up that
female animal's body and stores of these
essential nutrients so the embryo
implants in the uterine wall and
develops in an environment that has
optimal amounts guaranteed optimal
amounts of all the nutrients and you
will almost eliminate the possibility of
a congenital birth defect related to a
mineral or vitamin or amino acid or
essential fatty acid deficiency to give
you some idea of how successful this is
according to the University of
California San Francisco right now in
America one out of every 33 human babies
in America are born with some physical
or emotional or mental birth defect one
out of 33 in animals it's only one out
of five hundred thousand if they're fed
these commercial diets that have all the
known nutrients in them and so it is
very very easy to understand well if we
supplement young women and men who are
in the childbearing years with these
nutrients that will be able to eliminate
totally eliminate cleft palates cleft
lip spina bifida I defects heart defects
hernias various types clubfeet no feet
webbed fingers and toes no fingers and
toes muscular dystrophy Down syndrome
cerebral palsy cystic fibrosis these are
all preventable with proper
preconception nutrition so the earlier
that a couple who wants to have normal
healthy children have a wonderful
uncomplicated pregnancy the earlier you
can get on all 90 essential nutrients
prior to conception that better off
everybody is hello dr. Wallach the women
in my family are plagued with hay fever
and asthma and allergies and I don't
want to join those ranks is there a
better way absolutely let's start with
asthma is the easiest one to deal with
asthma is actually a deficiency of three
nutrients magnesium manganese and the
essential fatty acids and by taking the
pig arthritis formula twice a day you're
going to get the
optimal amounts of the plant derived
colloidal and the key lated magnesium
and manganese and then by taking the
minimum daily requirement the 9 grams of
the essential fatty acid and those three
nutrients together the magnesium
manganese the essential fatty acids will
allow you to produce what's called
prostaglandins prostaglandins or little
short lived hormones that last in your
bloodstream 30 seconds 60 seconds and
your body is continuously making a kind
of rapid fire and when you don't have
those three nutrients you cannot make
the proper prostaglandins to keep your
bronchi and your trachea open and that's
when you develop asthma and it's very
common when people take all 90 essential
nutrients including the magnesium and
manganese and essential fatty acids
within weeks or months the tightness
this constant tightness in their chest
is significantly reduced or maybe even
totally relieved the frequency and the
severity of their asthma attacks is
reduced I would certainly still keep an
inhaler available to you know in case
you have some unexpected emergency kind
of like wearing your seatbelt even
though you're on a smooth flight you
you're not going to anticipate sudden
turbulence you need to be prepared for
emergencies but a very honest
expectation of doing very well then as
far as inhalant allergies from dust and
pollen zand seasonal ones from dustin
pounds and maybe constant ones from
danders and cats and dogs and chickens
and feathers and your pillows and that
kind of thing maybe even chemicals that
come out of rugs and Formica and new
cars like formaldehyde other chemicals
you want to get your immune system
working optimally so it can protect you
from these things because most people
are able to tolerate them and what
happens is when your immune system
doesn't have enough nutrition to
function optimally you become a victim
of these things assaulting you all the
time and so what you want to do is
number one take all 90 essential
nutrients or your immune system which
includes your liver and your spleen your
tonsils and your appendix your thymus
your white blood cells which include the
neutrophils and the lymphocytes and the
killer t-cells and so forth also you
have eosinophils and basophils you have
neutrophils all of these that white
blood cells you have
albumins and globul ins which are the
immune proteins you have antibodies
themselves you have your digestive
system your skin your tears the mucus in
your body all of that requires 90
essential nutrients to produce this
immune system which is not just your
killer t-cells it includes all of these
tissues and cells and organs of your
body also if you have these types of
problems you want to get some of these
HEPA filters at your work place in your
home when you sleep you get the ones
that you plug in your car you want to
eat as much organically grown food as
possible you want to drink filtered
water you want to get as much chemicals
out of your diet as possible and to
reduce this pressure on your immune
system if you have food allergies you
want to have a five day rotation diet
you want to take the enzyme which has
the pepsin and the betaine hydrochloride
which will help a person digest the
proteins down into single amino acid and
it's the proteins and allergens such as
danders and foods and pollens and dust
that cause the the allergies and even
can initiate an attack of asthma thank
you you're very welcome is it possible
that you can take too much as a great
question because people are concerned
about overdosing with vitamins and
minerals the general answer is that if
you look at the medical profession
according to the Center for Disease
Control Harvard Medical School the US
News and World Report Ralph Nader's
Sidney Wolfe RAND Corporation and many
many other well respected institutions
they say that doctors kill 150,000 the
300,000 Americans each year in hospitals
alone as a result of medical negligence
dr. Zinder 1.3 million Americans each
year in hospitals loans result to
medical negligence and doctors infect
two million Americans alone in hospitals
as a result in medical negligence for a
total of three and a half million
casualties inflicted on American public
each year in hospitals just as a result
of medical negligence on the other side
of this picture there's not a single
person whose overdose and vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals to the point
where they have to be hospitalized or
anything bad happen and so when you
compare the safety of vitamins and mills
and trace minerals and compared with
standard medical procedures it's
enormously safe and that's why I'm
excited about nutrition and the pig
earth riders farm owned the plant
derived colloidal minerals and that's
the direction I'd go dr. Wallach my
sixteen-year-old daughter has been
diagnosed with fibromyalgia what can you
do for her well it's actually an easy
one we eliminated fibromyalgia and
animals in 1957 and sheep it was called
stiff lamb disease and also in sheep and
calves and foals and baby horses and
chickens and turkeys and any any other
animal that was raised for meat the
disease is caused by a deficiency of
three nutrients the trace mineral
selenium vitamin e and the sulfur
bearing amino acid methionine and
there's two things you have to do to
deal with fibromyalgia number 1
eliminate the free radicals and the
trans fatty acids that actually initiate
damage to the muscle it causes scarring
of the muscle tissue which is very
painful even normal muscle movement and
you can understand what they call it
stiff lamb disease if you have
fibromyalgia first of all you eliminate
fried foods such as fried potatoes which
are you know teenagers live on fried
potatoes right so cavity eliminate fried
potatoes fried chicken fish shrimp fried
eggs tempura stir fry anything fried all
margarine salad dressings with oils in
them have to be eliminated and then
again the pig Earthrise ron was perfect
because it has optimal amounts of the
trace mineral selenium in both the plant
derived coal oil and the key lated form
has optimal amounts of vitamin E and the
sulfur bearing amino acid Matheny and it
just works like a charm very quickly
within weeks or months so they feel and
they can recognize some benefit and many
people get significant benefit very
quickly dr. Baugh like our baby formulas
enough for our babies when they're born
unfortunately not our formulas that we
give to dogs whether it was kind of like
science that dog food are the puppy or
kitten milk replacers for puppies and
kittens you're in raised by hand have 40
minerals in them including the minerals
lithium chromium vanadium and selenium
ralston purina laboratory rat pellets
contained 28 minerals including lithium
chromium vanadium selenium there's not a
single human milk replacer on the market
on a off the shelf ago surrey store has
more than 12 minerals none of them
contain lithium chromium vanadium and
only two
soy bien enfamil have slim in them and
it's tragic that we give our dogs 40
minerals in our rats 28 and our kids 12
or less you can begin to see why we
spent 1.2 trillion dollars for health
care last year you begin to see why we
only live to be 75.5 half of our genetic
potential for longevity of 120 140 why
we only ranked 17th and longevity in
19th and health and us simply because we
don't get the basic raw materials to
develop properly and maintain repair
cells from the very beginning i'll give
you a tragic example sudden infant death
syndrome is something everybody is
familiar with we eliminated sudden
infant death syndrome on animals back in
the 1950s because farmers can't afford
to lose two or three or five or ten
percent of the baby animals are raising
too sudden infant death syndrome we
learned that was due to a deficiency of
the trace mineral slam causing sudden
death and the most robust the healthiest
of the baby animals in the group or the
herd of the flock and we eliminate it
simply by giving the pregnant mothers
selenium and as soon as the baby is born
hatch they get selenium and if you look
at the human infant milk replacers on
the market only two of all of them put
selenium in the formal and so if i was
going to raise a child today on these
infant milk replacers these infant milk
formulas in a can or a borrower box i
would pick the two pro soybean enfamil
that have selenium in them and to stack
things in favor of the child i would
still give them from the moment they're
born a teaspoon for 20 pounds of body
weight of the peter thrives from with
twice a day obviously you may not want
to use the orange juice and a newborn
baby cuz they can develop allergies to
it but i would still give them the plant
derived plural and the key lated
minerals and vitamins and amino acids
and the tragic example of this is
sixty-five percent this is a known fact
sixty-five percent of all the babies
dying of sudden infant death syndrome in
America are being fed can milk replacers
two-thirds are the ones who died of
sudden infant death syndrome are being
fed these canned infant formulas i
guarantee a-- they're being fed the ones
that don't have selenium in them and so
absolutely it's important to supplement
these babies from birth because you
can't get everything you need from
airport food groups certainly not all
these canned farm
great thank you